AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TODAY'S
HEARING HAPPY SUNDAY EVERYBODY
DUE TO THE CONTINUED STATE HOME
ORDERS WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE ARE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE
IN THE HEARING. IN PERSON. WE
ARE ALSO REQUIRING THAT MASK BE
WORN PHYSICAL. AND PHYSICAL
DISTANCE TO BE MAINTAINED BY
ALL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM ARE AT THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU. BECAUSE OF OUR
SPACE LIMITATIONS WE HAVE SOME
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SITTING AT
THE DIETS AND OTHER SITTING IN
THE FIRST FEW ROWS OF SEATS IN
THE AUDIENCE FOR THOSE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK DURING THE HEARING.
PLEASE APPROACH THE MIKE BEHIND
THE PLEXIGLAS AND PLEASE
REMEMBER TO PRACTICE OF THE
CIRCLE DISTANCING. WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESSES TESTIMONY TODAY. IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC HERE
IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY ON A BILL PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND AND I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING RETURN TO YOUR SEAT
PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE HEARING ROOM.
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
FOR DIALING WITNESSES. WE WILL
ALSO BE USING MODERATE
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND THE AREA CODE.
AN ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO AGAIN.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU ARE CALLING IN
THESE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT. OR OPPOSE
A BILL. IF YOU ARE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR
SMART DEVICE REDUCE THIS DOWN.
DISTORTION IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATE
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE.TWO ZERO NINE
EIGHT AND MYSELF WILL BE THERE
TO TRY TO HELP YOU. I ALSO WANT
TO NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WE NEED TO
NEED TO LIMIT HOW LONG THE
PHONE LINES ARE OPEN FOR EACH
BILL AS WE ARE ON A TIGHT.
HEARING SCHEDULE. THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE. NOW
BEFORE WE TAKE UP THE FIRST
BILL I'D LIKE TO REVIEW
ADDITIONAL HOUSEKEEPING
ANNOUNCEMENTS FOR THE BILLS
BEING TAKEN UP TODAY WE WILL
TAKE NO MORE THAN TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND TO
PRIMING WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ORWITH CONCERNS. THESE NET
WITNESSES WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES
EACH PROVIDE THEIR TESTIMONY
ALL SUBSEQUENT WITNESSES SHOULD
STATE THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE BILL ONLY. CONTINGENT
UPON OTHER AVAILABILITY WE WILL
BE HEARING BILLS TODAY IN THE
FOLLOWING ORDER. FIRSTSB FIFTY
ONE BY CENTER DORADO SECOND S.
B. FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AND COVER
YOUR- AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES THIRD AB TWO SEVENTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
AND FINALLY WILL TAKE UP MY
BILL FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN.
FINALLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS
HAS BEEN APPOINTED AS VICE
CHAIR AND IT'S ONLY MEMBER
KILEY HAS BEEN APPOINTED TO
FILL REPUBLICAN VACANCY BOTH
APPOINTMENTS ARE FOR THIS
HEARING ONLY. HI WE HAVE A
QUORUM. MISTER ROUGHLY CALL THE
ROLL.
WELCOME SIR DRAWS OF
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. OKAY.
RIGHT RENDON MANAGER- MEDICARE
MEMBERS WITH. MULLIN SHOT INTO
WHAT IS EXPECTED TO BE A LONG
SLUGGISH RECOVERY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY WITHOUT
INCREASING THE NET COST TO
TAXPAYERS IT WOULD MAKE THE
CALIFORNIA COMPETES TAX CREDIT
MORE ATTRACTIVE TO LARGE
COMPANIES WILLING TO LOCATE
BUILD AND EXPAND MEDIA
PRODUCTION INFRASTRUCTURE IN
CALIFORNIA AS LONG AS THEY CAN
COMMIT TO CREATING FIVE
THOUSAND FULL TIME JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA. GOING FORWARD FOR
AT LEAST TEN YEARS THIS IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY COMMITMENT TO
HIGH WAGE HIGH SKILL JOBS. I
BELIEVE WITH THE RIGHT
INCENTIVES COMPANIES ARE READY
TO EXPAND IN OUR STATE AND KEEP
CALIFORNIA THE MEDIA AND
CONTENT PRODUCTION CAPITAL OF
THE WORLD. IN EXCHANGE THIS
BILL ALLOWS THOSE CAL COMPETES
AWARD HE'S- WILLING TO MEET
THESE CRTERIA TO APPLY ALL OR
PART OF THE LORD TO OFFSET
AGAINST ITS TOTAL STATE TAX
LIABILITY. TO BE CLEAR NO ONE
COMPANY OR INDUSTRY IS
GUARANTEED A CALICO PETE'S
AWARD UNDER THIS BILL.
COMPANIES MUST STILL APPLY MAKE
THEIR CASE AND UNDERGO THE
USUAL COMPETITIVE PROCESS ORTIZ
WAS STILL DEMONSTRATE
COMPLIANCE WITH GO BIZ AND
UNDERGO IF TO BE AUDITS. IN THE
END IF SB FIFTY ONE REPRESENTS
A GREAT DEAL FOR WORKERS AND A
HUGE POTENTIAL ECONOMIC WIN FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WITHOUT INCREASING COSTS TO
TAXPAYERS IT PROVIDES TAX
FLEXIBILITY WITH AN EXISTING
PROGRAM IN EXCHANGE FOR
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
COMMITMENT AND THOUSANDS OF NEW
HIGH WAGE FULL TIME JOBS. FOR
WORKING CALIFORNIANS THIS BILL
IS SUPPORTED BY THE
ENTERTAINMENT UNION COALITION
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA I HAD TO
COUNSEL TEAMSTERS LOCAL THREE
NINETY NINE LABOUR'S LOCAL
SEVEN TWENTY FOUR. THE SAG
AFTRA. IT IS ALSO SUPPORTED BY
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES. I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER IAN
CALDERON WHO LIKE ME REPRESENTS
THOUSANDS OF MEDIA PRODUCTION
WORKERS IN HIS DISTRICT. HAS
BEEN WORKING NEARLY HIS ENTIRE
CAREER AND CREATIVE WAYS TO
ATTRACT AND RETAIN MORE HIGH
WAGE MEDIA AND ENTERTAINMENT
JOBS IN CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
RAISES SOME IMPORTANT POINTS
ABOUT THE CRITERIA WHICH WE
INTEND TO CLARIFY IN A LETTER
TO THE JOURNAL. AND I WANT TO
THANK THE GOVERNOR STAFF
INCLUDING HIS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. WHICH
HAS PROVEN VALUABLE PROVIDED
VALUABLE TECHNICAL EXPERTS-
MANAGER WE HAVE TOM DAVIS
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA ATTY
COUNCIL- ALL WOULD TO BE OUR-
THE WITNESS ON THE LINE. AND IN
CLOSING I JUST ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SORRY WE'RE JUST HAVING A
LITTLE TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON. NO
BURKE IN IRELAND. WE GOT IT.
THERE WE GO THANK YOU I JUST
WANT TO THINK- THE CHAIR AND
HER COMMITTEE FOR WORKING ON
THIS BILL WITH US IN AND FOR-
ALLOWING THIS BILL TO BE SAID
HEARD THANK YOU SO MUCH I
APPRECIATE THAT THE INDULGENCE
OF YOURSELF UNTIL TO THE
COMMITTEE ALSO WANT TO THANK
SENATOR DRAWS OVER LEADERSHIP
IN THIS AREA AND WORKING WTH
ME- ON THIS ISSUE AND QUITE
SIMPLY THIS IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA
TALKING PEACE TAX COURT HAS
ALREADY FUNDED THIS REQUIRES NO
NEW MONEY FROM CALIFORNIA IT'S
ALREADY EXISTING MONEY. THAT IS
DEDICATED TO THIS PROGRAM AND
IT'S GOING TO PROVIDE US A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO BRING A
LOT OF JOBS AND INFRASTRUCTURE
TO THE STATE WHICH IS IMPORTANT
I THINK ALL OF US ARE AWARE
THAT THIS STATE HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY BEHIND IN TERMS
OF OUR INFRASTRUCTURE WITH
REGARDS TO THIS INDUSTRY I AND
THIS IS GONNA ALLOW US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET TO THE POINT
WHERE- THERE'S MORE
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IS GOING
TO PROVIDE MORE OPPORTUNITY FOR
JOBS. AND CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY
DURING A TIME- WITH COVE IN
NINETEEN AND A LACK OF-
ECONOMIC STIMULUS OUT THERE
THIS IS GOING TO BE A REALLY
IMPORTANT TIME FOR THIS THAT TO
BE HAPPENING I ALSO WANT TO
MAKE A POINT OF CLARIFICATION I
WAS TALKING A COUPLE COLLEAGUES
ON THE FLOOR SPECIFIC TO THIS
ISSUE ABOUT THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR FOR CORPORATE
CORPORATION- ACTION THAT WE
TOOK EARLIER IN THE YEAR WITH
RELATES THE BUDGET. THAT WOULD
STILL APPLY TO THIS HOWEVER THE
CAL COMPETES TAX CREDIT ANY
EVERYBODY ELSE APPLY THE EXACT
SAME THEY CAN AWARD MORE THAN
THE FIVE MILLION PER YEAR FOR
THE IF THEY CAN UTILIZE MORE
THAN FIVE MILLION FOR THREE
YEARS HOWEVER THEY CAN UTILIZE
IT AFTER THAT SO JUST GIVE THEM
MORE FLEXIBILITY TO DO THIS AND
THAT MONEY ALL HAS TO GO INTO
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE SO IS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY- AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU I UNDERSTAND WE
ARE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF FIRST PRIMARY
WITNESSES. DO WE STILL HAVE
ARTHUR DON'T KNOW I'VE NEVER
UNABLE TO HE WAS UNABLE TO BE A
SO JUST ALL RIGHT THIS IS JUST
NOT OKAY ALL RIGHT MODERATOR WE
PLEASE CONNECT US WITH US WITH
PRIMARY. TOM DAVIS WITH AYE ON.
THESE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN SIR
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH-
TOM BAYLISSTHE- PRESIDENT OF
THE I. CALIFORNIA IF THE
COUNCIL ENTERTAINMENT UNIT
COALITIONS WHAT THE BUSINESS
MANAGER FIVE YEARS THE LOCAL
EIGHTY OFFICE I'D LIKE TO
UPDATE THAT TO ALL THE SUPPORT.
AND AGREE WITH SENATOR OSLO'S A
STATEMENT ON THIS BILL AND I
ALSO WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IAN CALDERON COURT
TIRELESS WORK ON THIS MATTER-
THIS BILL REPRESENTS- UP A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I BELIEVE THAT-
WITH PASSAGE OF THIS BILL AND-
BE COMPETITIVE BIDDING PROCESS
THAT WILL BE TAKING PLACE BUT
THIS IS GOING TO CREATE-
THOUSANDS OF JOBS. WE'RE NOT
JUST THOSE OF US IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY BUT ALSO
PER ON BOTH WORKERS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES AS WELL SO
ON WITHOUT I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME MMHM. I'M ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU DAVE IF THE
WOULD NOW OPEN UP THE LINE FOR
AND IS SO. TO PLEASE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO WISH TO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. PRESS ONE ZERO. I WILL
NOW GO TO LINE UP TO SIXTY NINE
THE LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
CHAIR MEMBERS PROPOSAL GET OFF
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI IN SUPPORT
AT THE FIFTY ONE THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY DETERMINED ONE FINAL
CALL PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I'M SURE THERE IS NO
WINNING TO RESPOND TO COMMENTS.
OKAY THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE REMOTE VIDEO STATION AT
THIS TIME. SEEING NONE IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WITH THE MODERATOR
PLEASE NOW OPEN THE MAINLINE
FOR ANY OPPOSITION TERM
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU I DON'T
CARE AND AGAIN- TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION THIS PRESS ONE ZERO
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THE MAN CARE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE WE
DO HAVE ONE PERSON QUEUED UP
RIGHT NOW THE OPERATORS
PROCESSING THEM THROUGH JUST A
MOMENT THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
WE HAVE ONLY A ONE ADDITIONAL
LINE AND THAT PERSON IS TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT NOT OPPOSITION
WE HAVE NO ONE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. I THEY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. BEST
MANAGER I BELIEVE THAT IS
CORRECT I WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO
OPEN THE LINE NOW PLEASE. BY
TWO FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI AT THIS IS THERE IN MY
HAND CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA
AND DEPORTED SB FIFTY ONE.
STANDING WITH THE UNION DIDN'T
CORD DESTRY I AT THE TEAMSTERS
AND SAG AFTRA THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WITH THAT IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFYIN
OPPOSITION VIA REMOTE VIDEO
STATION AT THIS TIME. NOW IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE DR
CORK. WELL IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHAT'S IN
THE BILL JUST BECAUSE IT COMES
UP LATE I'M JUST READING THE
MALICE IS NOW. BUT ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS IS THESE FIVE
THOUSAND JOBS. IS THAT MEAN
FIFTY THOUSAND JOBS OR DOES IT
SEEM FIVE THOUSAND JOBS AND
CONTINUE FOR TEN YEARS. SO IF I
HAVE AN ENTERPRISE AND I'VE
DONE THIS AND I. HAVE FIVE
THOUSAND JOBS ONE DAY ONE- AND
THEY PROCESS FOR TEN YEARS
WITHOUT SATISFIED OR DO THEY
NEED TO HAVE AN ADDITIONAL.
FIVE THOUSAND EVERY YEAR OR
MAYBE IT AND HIGHER FIFTY
THOUSAND. YES IS. AS FAR AS I-
I SEE IT THE AUTHORITIES MUST
COMMIT TO CREATING FIVE
THOUSAND OF FULL TIME JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA EVERY YEAR. SO IF
THEY DO FIVE THOUSAND SO IT
WOULD BE FIFTY THOUSAND SO THEY
HAVE TO GO FROM WHATEVER THEY
HAVE NW FIVE THOUSAND TEN
THOUSAND FIFTEEN THOUSAND.
TWENTY THOUSAND INTERVENTION OF
REACH FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
WELL IT'S FIVE THOUSAND EVERY
YEAR. WELL EVERY YEAR I'M NOT
SO DOCTOR PARK I BELIEVE THAT
SOME OF YOU WILL WERE TALKING
ABOUT WILL BE IN THE LETTER TO
CLARIFY AS WE'RE NOT IT IS A
AND IT IS NOT CLEAR IN THE BILL
IF THAT IS FIVE THOUSAND RE
HIRES OF THAT FIVE THOUSAND NEW
JOBS SO I BELIEVE THAT THAT'S
ONE OF THE THINGS. THAT WHEN
THEY SEE ABOUT THE LETTER TO
THE JOURNAL THAT IS TO BE
CLARIFIED IN THAT LETTER. OFTEN
WHETHER OR NOT I DO. I DON'T. I
DON'T HAVE A COPY OF THAT
LETTER WHENEVER COPY OF A
LETTER CONTAINS DOWN. HAVEN'T
READ TO US. I WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THAT AND DR CORRECT
YOU HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION OR WE
CAN MOVE ON AND THEN COME BACK
TO DR CORPUS MORE WILL MOVE ON
OKAY YOU KNOW WHAT'S IN THE
LETTER. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHIS. THANK MADAM.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- SWANA
THANK THE SENATOR AND- MISTER
CALDERON FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND I KNOW IT'S KIND OF
LAST MINUTE BUT RIGHT NOW WITH
CODE AND EVERYTHING ELSE WE
DEFINITELY MADE TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE GETTING JOBS- IN A LOT OF
PEOPLE FORGET ABOUT- INYO
COUNTY WHICH HAPPENS TO BE IN
MY DISTRICT WHICH HAPPENS TO BE
THE- BACK LOT FOR HOLLYWOOD'S
WHO ACTUALLY APPRECIATE THIS
BILL- AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
MOTION. TO MOVE THE BILL
FORWARD. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS CONCERNS IT'S
PETRIE-NORRIS. THE SENATOR- I
FIND MYSELF A LITTLE BIT
CONFLICTED- BECAUSE I LIKE
MISTER MATHIS COMMEND YOU FOR
THIS FILM TO TRY TO STIMULATE
THE ECONOMY TO CREATE JOBS
COULD NOT AGREE WITH YOU MORE
THAT WE NEED AN ADRENALINE SHOT
IN THE ARM AT THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY I GUESS I'M CONFUSED
ABOUT IS WHY IS THIS
RESTRICTED. TO ONLY COMPANIES.
THAT ENGAGE IN MEDIA PRODUCTION.
COULD WE- PRODUCTS YES I'LL
EXPLAIN AS MUCH AS I CAN AND
THEN MAYBE MISTER DAVIS OR-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON WANT
TO JUMP IN ONE IS THAT WE FOUND
THAT THERE IS A GREAT NEED
PRIOR TO THE OF PANDEMIC
KIDDING ARE THERE WAS 95% OF
USE THERE USING95% OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THIS OF THE
RECORDING STUDIOS AND THIS
PERMANENT YOU KNOW-
INFRASTRUCTURE. SO WE WERE
GETTING READY TO JUST OUT- NOT
BE IN A POSITION TO KEEP
GROWING BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE AND SO
WE'RE GONNA LOSE PRODUCTION
BECAUSE WE WERE NOT IN A
POSITION TO KEEP IT HERE IN THE
STATE SO IS VERY MUCH GETTING
TO THE POINT WHERE WE COULD
HAVE LOST THOSE JOBS OUT OF
CALIFORNIA SO I KNOW THE
PANDEMICS HIT BUT WE DON'T WANT
TO WAIT BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY YOU
CAN BUILD THIS OVERNIGHT WE
DON'T WANT TO WAIT WE KNOW WE
HAVE THE ABILITY. TO CREATE FAR
FAR MORE JOBS IN CALIFORNIA
THROUGH THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY WE WANT TO BE IN A
POSITION TO KEEP CONTINUE TO BE
THE CAPITAL OF ENTERTAINMENT
FOR THE COUNTRY AND YOU KNOW
ONE OF THE CAPITALS OF THE
WORLD SO WE WANT TO BE IN A
POSITION TO BE ABLE TO CREATE
THE JOBS NOW AND BE READY AS
THE BUSINESS PICKS UP FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO ABSORB IT AND- SEOUL
THAT'S ONE REASON I DID NOT-
MISTER DAVIS IF YOU WANT TO ADD
TO THAT. THANK YOU LAW CENTER.
YEAH WHAT ONE OF THE- ISSUE
USERS APLIK WRECKED ON ON THE
WANTING TO BE READY FOR-
PRODUCTION ASSEMBLY THAT WE
BELIEVE AND WHAT WAS THAT WOULD
NOT BE COMING BACK. AFTER ON IT
WE PASSED THIS. THIS THIS
HORRIFIC. UP PANDEMIC THAT
WE'RE EXPERIENCING. THE PUT
DOWN MAKE ON THAT THUNDER. WE
ARE AT NEAR CAPACITY THE
INDUSTRY. AND WE HAD UP MORE
COMPANIES SPEAKING- TO COME
YOUR DOCTOR COMPACT CALIFORNIA
FROM OTHER STATES. SO IT IS
NEEDED INFRASTRUCTURE BUT ALSO
I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT. OF
THIS. IS THAT WHEN WE HAVE
THESE COMPANIES WHO ARE WILLING
TO MAKE THIS TYPE COMMITMENT.
pGROWTH OF TH JOBS IT ALSO
MAKES A COMMITMENT TO THE
STATE. AND I THINK THAT- THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT COMPONENT.
ANYTHING THAT THAT THE STATE
CAN DO. WITH THE DOLLARS THAT
ARE ALREADY ALLOCATED. IS TO
HAVE THOSE INVESTED IN SUCH A
WAY THAT IS GOING TO- COULD NOT
JUST A PROMISE OF THE JOBS BUT
THE GUARANTEE- IN ORDER TO
FULFILL THE COMMITMENT ORDERS
TO GET THE UP. IF THE SERBS.
THEY HAVE TO ACTUALLY CREATE
THE JOB NOT JUST- YOU KNOW SAY
THAT WELL IF WE DO THIS THEN
THE JOBS ARE PROBABLY BE
CREATED THIS IS AN ACTUAL
COMMITMENT. OVER TIME. IN ON TO
AN INDUSTRY THAT- IS SEARCH
SYNONYMOUS WITH CALIFORNIA. AND
WE BELIEVE. THAT THIS IS GOOD
PUBLIC POLICY. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS IDEA BUT I DON'T KNOW
MISTER AT OUR- BURKE CALDERON
IS GONNA THANK AYE PROJECTS
ACTUALLY REALLY GREAT QUESTION
I THINK IT SHOULD BE OPEN TO A
LOT MORE INDUSTRIES ANYBODY
WHO'S WILLING TO MAKE THIS KIND
OF INVESTMENT THE STATE. THE
KIND OF THERE'S TWO ISSUES THAT
THE FIRST ISSUES IT IS YOU KNOW
UNDERGO SEASONS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE I THINK YEAH
AND THE ADMINISTRATION THIS IS
KIND OF MORE THE FOLKS THAT
THEY WANTED TO BE. WE ALSO HAVE
BEEN TRYING TO FIND A WAY TO
MAKE OUR TAX CREDITS A LITTLE
BIT MORE USEFUL AS TIME GOES
ON. AND I THINK THAT THAT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
THAT GROWTH- AND THIS IS A
GREAT START TO THAT AND I THINK
IF THIS IS SUCCESSFUL WE CAN
EXPAND THAT TO OTHER
INDUSTRIES. BUT IT'S ALL WAS
ALSO ASKED OF US BY CAL
COMPETES THEMSELVES- IF WE
COULD ALSO NARROW AND SPECIFIC
TO THE INDUSTRY GIVEN WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR THE TYPES OF
IN A TYPE OF INVESTMENT ITSELF.
YOU KNOW ORIGINALLY THE
LANGUAGE WAS TO BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE BROAD BUT THIS IS KIND OF
WHAT WE ENDED UP WITH THROUGH
THE NEGOTIATION PROCESS- BUT I
CERTAINLY WOULD ENCOURAGE
ESPECIALLY IF THIS IS
SUCCESSFUL WHICH I BELIEVE WILL
BE SUCCESSFUL. TO OPEN THAT UP-
TO OTHER INDUSTRIES AND YOU
KNOW I JUST THINK THAT WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
MODERNIZATION OF OUR TAX CREDIT
PROGRAMS. TO ALLOW THEM TO BE
APPLICABLE AND RELEVANT AS WE
MOVE ON TO BE ABLE TO FLY FOR
BUSINESS IS STATES HERE TO KEEP
THAT- KEEP THAT INVESTMENT.
CONTINUALLY COMING TO
CALIFORNIA. AND THEY'LL WANT
THEY WILL WANT TO BE HERE
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO BE
EXPENSIVE TO MOVE TO OTHER
STATES THERE'S HOT THERE'S
COVERT REST ESPECIALLY WITHIN
THIS INDUSTRY SO. THIS IS WHAT
THE PRODUCTION OF YOU KNOW ALL
A LOT OF OTHER FOLKS BEING
INVOLVED. IN A VERY VERY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME BUT THAT'S
ULTIMATELY WHY WE LANDED ON
THIS IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITIES
GONNA BUT IT BRING A LOT OF
ECONOMIC REVENUE. CERTAINLY
WORTH DOING RIGHTNOW- AND THEN
HOPEFULLY. EXPANDING LATER ON.
DEMOCRATIC I THINK EVERYTHING
EVERYTHING. A CENTER. THAT BUT
YOU. TERMS OF FIFTEEN AND
IMPORTANT. FOR US TO SUPPORT. A
REALLY IMPORTANT HISTORY. AND
EVERYTHING THAT. ABDOMINAL THE
PHONE SAID. TOTALLY AGREE I
THINK I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SEE
THE REFUND ABILITY. AS THE C.
C. T. C. LIKE. PROVIDE ANYONE
WHO MEETS THAT CRITERIA BECAUSE
WE NEED TO CREATE. WE NEED TO
CREATE JOBS AND STIMULATE THIS
ECONOMY NOT JUST IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY WE NEED
YEAH. CLEAN ENERGY. LIFE
SCIENCES. AGRICULTURE RIGHT SO.
I'M I HOPE THAT WE CAN. FIND A
WAY. IT'S NOT IT'S I DON'T KNOW.
I NOT A PART OF THIS ARE PART
OF THE VOTE. INTERNET WORK.
THAT CONVERTS. YEP IF I COULD
JUST ADD ONE MORE THING IS. I
FEEL VERY CONFIDENT YOU KNOW
ALL I HAVE A- HISTORY OF
WORKING WITH NOT ONLY THIS
INDUSTRY BUT A LOT OF
INDUSTRIES. WELL IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA LOS ANGELES AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE INVESTMENT
IS GOING TO BE FOR HIGH WAGE
JOBS. THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
JOBS THAT NO WE COULD FAMILIES
COULD REALLY. OF THE WORKERS
COULD REALLY RAISE OUR FAMILIES
WHAT AND ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE
COMPANY'S. I REALLY BELIEVE YOU
KNOW A COMPANY'S PROMISE SHOULD
BE LIVED UP TO. AND YOU KNOW TO
HAVE A PROGRAM WHERE THAT'S
GOING TO BE. AN ABSOLUTE
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR ACCOUNTABILITY
MEANS A LOT TO ME BECAUSE THESE
ARE VERY PRECIOUS TAX DOLLARS.
THANK YOU. MISTER AND- YEAH.
BAKER PROBABLY HEARING BETTER
THANK YOU. SENATOR SEVERAL
YEARS AGO THE UNITED STATES
SENATOR AND NOW VICE
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES THIS
COMMENT HAS CAME THROUGH MY
DISTRICT. CAMPAIGNING AND WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SIT WITH
HER- MYSELF CENTER GALGIANI
FROM MY AREA. WITH SOME OF THE
LEADERS IN THE AGRICULTURE
INDUSTRY. M. WE HAD A TABLE WE
WENT AROUND THE ROOM AND
EVERYBODY INTRODUCED THEMSELVES
FROM POULTRY- ALMONDS
PISTACHIOS AND OTHER CROPS.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON ROOM
INTRODUCED THEMSELVES TO THE
SENATOR AS A SMALL FAMILY
FARMERS. SO WHENEVER WE GOT
DONE TALKING I SAID TO THE
GROUP I SAID YOU KNOW WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT TO MY FRIENDS HERE
MOSIS FOLKS IN THIS ROOM THESE
INDUSTRY LEADERS ARE NOT SMALL
FAMILY FARMERS THE PRETTY BIG
FAMILY FOR. I SAID THAT THEY
HAVE TO INTRODUCE THEMSELVES TO
YOU THAT WAY. BECAUSE OTHERWISE
THEY'RE GREEDY CORPORATE FOR. I
SAID ENOUGH I CAN DO YOUR
DISTRICT IN SAN FRANCISCO WOOD
GOOGLE AND APPLE AND ALL THESE
FOLKS INTRODUCED THEMSELVES TO
ME A SMALL FAMILY TECH
COMPANIES. THEY WOULDN'T
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE TO. I
WOULD SAY THE SAME THING ABOUT
OUR FRIENDS IN LOS ANGELES ARE
WE SMALL FAMILY PRODUCTION
COMPANIES NO NO WE'RE NOT. BUT
THERE'S DISCRIMINATORY
ATTITUDES IN THIS BODY AND IN
THE STATE AND MANY FROM OUR
URBAN COLLEAGUES IN BOTH THE
BAY AREA LOS ANGELES. SO SOME
INDUSTRIES ARE GOOD SOME
INDUSTRIES ARE BAD HERE WE FIND
OURSELVES IN THE THROES. OF
BLAST IS LEGISLATURE AND WALSH.
YOU KNOW THE SENATE HASN'T HAD
THE TIME TO TAKE TAPE UP THE
VAPING TAX I WAS WORKING ON
OVER THERE AT THE TIME TO MAKE
SURE THAT MILITARY VETERANS CAN
USE THEIR LICENSES TO. DO THEIR
WORK HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
FINDING TIME TO EXPAND CREDITS
FOR HOLLYWOOD AND FOR LOS
ANGELES. AND I UNDERSTAND YOU
NOT SPEND NEW MONEY THAT I
UNDERSTAND I'VE WORKED WITH THE
SAME NUMBER CALDERON TO PASS ON
SOME OF THESE BILLS NOT
SUPPORTED THESE BILLS. IN THE
PAST. BUT I'D BE RESIDENTS DID
NOT. MAKE THE POINT THE POINT
THAT MY COLLEAGUE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS WAS MAKING
WHICH IS. STARTS TO FEEL LIKE.
IT'S ALWAYS AN EMERGENCY IT'S
ALWAYS IMPORTANT WHAT L. A.
NEED SOMETHING OR SAM CISCO
NEED SOMETHING. IT IS NOT AS
IMPORTANT WHEN THE REST OF US
ITSELF AND SO A BROADER
APPROACH TO SOME OF THESE-
INCENTIVES AND TAX CREDITS AND
DOING THE THINGS THAT WE NEED
TO DO TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
INDUSTRIES FROM AGRICULTURE. TO
A MOVIE PRODUCTIONS TO LIFE
SCIENCES AND EVERYTHING IN
BETWEEN HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO. AS BEST THEY CAN GET
THROUGH THIS OBVIOUSLY.
UNPRECEDENTED WORLD CRISIS THAT
WE'RE ALL LIVING TO THIS
ECONOMIC RECESSION THAT EXISTS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY. AND
THERE'S ALWAYS PROMISES THAT
WE'RE GONNA GET TAKEN CARE OF
LATER AND THERE SHOULD BE
ANOTHER BILL AND THEN THE OTHER
BILLS COMMON THEY EXPLAIN TO-
THOSE OF US RURAL CALIFORNIA
HOW ARE PRIORITIES DON'T QUITE
MEET THE MARK ARE QUITE
IMPORTANT TO GET AHEAD IN LIFE.
SO I AGREE WITH THIS ON THIS
POINT WHICH IS WE SHOULD BE
BROADENING THIS IF IT CAN'T
HAPPEN TODAY IN THIS COMMITTEE.
MAYBE IT CAN HAPPEN. IN SOME
OTHER BILLS PROBABLY NOT THIS
YEAR I'M SURE AT THIS POINT I
THINK WE'RE BEYOND THE SEVENTY
TWO HOUR- MEHMET SO IT'S-
THERE'S ALWAYS IF THERE'S A
WILL THERE'S A WAY ALTHOUGH I
DOUBT THERE'S THE WILL TO FIND
A WAY TO HELP THE REST OF US.
BUT I'M GOING TO ATTEMPT TO
APPEAL TO THE BETTER ANGELS OF
MY NATURE HERE AND SUPPORT WHAT
I KNOW IS A- EFFORT WITH MERIT
TO HELP PEOPLE WORKING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE DO INCREASE AND MAINTAIN
HIGH WAGE JOBS WHICH IS THE
VALUE I KNOW WE ALL SHARE. AND
WANT TO DOUBLE DOWN AND I
COMMEND YOU FOR THAT WORK BUT-
I JUST HAD TO TAKE A MOMENT TO.
MAKE THE POINT SO THE NEXT TIME
WE'RE STAND ON THE SENATE
FLOOR. AND WE'RE HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT PRIORITIES.
THAT WE CAN ALL REMEMBER FROM
ALL PARTS OF THE STATE THAT WE
ALL HAVE PRIORITIES WE ALL HAVE
DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES. AND WE
ALL NEED HELP DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENT. SOME OF MY
ROOMMATES AND- JUST TO JUST TO
WITH MY CON I'M GONNA SUPPORT
THIS TODAY I DON'T KNOW I KNOW
THAT THERE IS A MOTION I'M
GONNA SECOND THE MOTION IF IT
HASN'T ALREADY BEEN SECOND-
MADAM CHAIR- BUT I JUST WANTED
TO- THE PIGGY BACK ON. MY
COLLEAGUES FROM FROM MERCED
SAYS COMMENTS- BECAUSE- IT'S
TRUE IF YOU'RE IN AT IN IN
AGRICULTURE- YOU CAN'T PICK UP.
YOUR DIRT. AND MOVE IT TO
ANOTHER STATE YOU ARE HERE. IT
IS A FACT- THAT CALIFORNIA
STACKS IS- ARE TOO HIGH- AND
IT'S ALSO A FACT THAT OUR
REGULATIONS ARE TOO ARE TOO
DEEP- BUT WHAT IS ALSO A FACT
IT WHEN YOU'RE IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT BUSINESS. IS YOU
ACTUALLY CAN'T TAKE YOUR
PRODUCTION- ELSEWHERE YOU CAN
ACTUALLY TAKE YOUR INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY. AND MOVE IT AND MOVE
IT ELSEWHERE I WAS HAVING A
CONVERSATION WITH. OUR MAJORITY
LEADER A LITTLE BIT EARLIER
TELLING THE STORY. A FRIEND OF
MINE- WHO IS A DIRECTOR- FOR
ONE OF THE- FOR SEVERAL LARGE A
FILM'S. ANY SPENDING IT OFF A
LOT OF TIME IN ATLANTA GEORGIA-
AND WHY IS IT THAT HE SPENDING
TIME IN ATLANTA GEORGIA WELL
BECAUSE OF THE STATE OF
GEORGIA. I'M AS PROVIDED FOR A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TAX
CREDITS AND THEY'RE TRYING TO
TAKE THAT BUSINESS- THAT WE
HAVE HAD HERE IN CALIFORNIA FOR
A LONG TIME TRYING TO TAKE IT.
ELSEWHERE WE ARE IN A GLOBAL
ECONOMY AND WE HAVE TO BE
COMPETITIVE SO WHILE I DON'T
LIKE DOING THESE ONE OFFS IN
FACT IT IS UP TO ME. I WOULD
SUGGEST YOU DO WE WOULD
ACTUALLY LOOK AT OUR ENTIRE-
ARE TIRED TAX SYSTEM I WOULD
LOOK AT THE WAY THAT WE- WE
HAVE OUR REVENUE SYSTEM TO BE
ABLE TO. TO PAY FOR OUR BILLS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA I WOULD WANT
TO REFORM ALL OF IT- BUT I
DON'T HAVE THAT OPTION- AND IN
FACT I HAVEN'T SEEN ANYBODY YET
MY SIX YEARS THE LEGISLATURE.
WANTING TO STEP UP AND GO AND
GO DO THAT CALIFORNIA'S NOT
COMPETITIVE SO WHAT WE HAVE TO
DO. WE HAVE TO DO WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT BILLS LIKE THE ONE
THAT'S BEFORE US- AND SUPPORT
THINGS LIKE THIS I HOPE SOME
DAY WE COME TO GRIPS THE FACT.
THAT IT ISN'T JUST OF THE FILM
INDUSTRY IS NOT JUST THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY BUT IT'S
MANY INDUSTRIES THAT ARE
SUFFERING. IN THE STATE- AND I
KNOW AS WE GO THROUGH THE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS WHEN COMPANIES
ARE LOOKING AT TRYING TO- TO
THINK ABOUT HOW THEY'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO COMPETE THIS
GLOBAL ENVIRONMENT. THOSE
COMPANIES THINKING YOU KNOW WE
DON'T HAVE TO BE HERE ANY
LONGER- WE'VE GOT- WE'VE YOU
KNOW W'VE GOT ZOOM- NOW RIGHT
WE DON'T HAVE TO HAVE A
PRESENCE HERE- I WOULD IMAGINE
THAT THIS STATE THIS
LEGISLATURE IS GOING TO HAVE TO
START LOKING. AT AT OUR
OVERALL POLICY IN REGARDS TO
HOW WE DEAL WITH WITH REVENUE
AND DEAL DO WITH REGULATIONS
BUT FOR TENET TODAY THE BILL
BEFORE. US IS THIS ONE I'M
GONNA BE SUPPORTING IT. THANK
YOU. FOR ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
AND THEN I'M GONNA GIVE MINE
FIRST SENATOR RAZA I KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT- WORKERS ARE TO YOU
AND I KNOW THEM AND WE HAVE
SPOKEN RECENTLY HOW IMPORTANT
ACCOUNTABILITY IS TO AND I
APPRECIATE THAT AND TO SEND TO
I JUST GIVEN UPGRADE CENTER-
DOESN'T REMEMBER CALDERON I
KNOW THAT YOU HAVE SPENT. THE
BULK OF YOUR TIME WORKING ON
THESE ISSUES ESPECIALLY FROM
THE MOTION PICTURE PICTURE
INDUSTRY AND FOR THOSE WHO
DON'T KNOW MY DAUGHTER'S FATHER
IS AYE AUSSIE. AND SO YOU KNOW
I FIRSTHAND KNOW ABOUT FAMILIES
BEING SEPARATED BECAUSE- OTHER
STATES ARE OFFERING CREDITS TO
PRODUCTION AND SO WE DO
UNDERSTAND THAT HOWEVER I DO
HAVE TO CONCUR WITH MOST OF MY
MATHIS. COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT.
THE FACT THAT THIS IS A SINGLE
INDUSTRY IS VERY CONCERNING TO
ME- YOU KNOW WE JUST DID IT BUT
WE JUST THROUGH THE BUDGET WE
RESTRICTED OTHER INDUSTRIES
CREDIT OPPORTUNITIES-
INDUSTRIES THAT WE ACTUALLY
REALLY DO ARE RELYING ON TO
PULL US OUT OF THIS ECONOMIC
CRISIS THAT WERE IN. A SOMEONE
WITH COBIT I AM WHO ARE WHO TAG
OF IT YOU KNOW THERE ARE
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE STRUGGLING
THAT. THAT WE NEED TO LIFT
OURSELVES OUT OF THIS AND THAT
CONCERNS ME THAT WE ARE MAKING
THIS VERY THINKS SINGULAR
INDUSTRY. TO MR MAYES IS POINT.
I AM ALSO CONCERNED I HAVE
GRAVE ONCERNS ABOUT THE FACT
THAT NOT JUST WITH THIS BILL
BUT THAT IN GENERAL THAT WE ARE
SIGNING NEW TAXES AND ASSIGNING
CREDITS THROUGH THIS PROCESS OF
THE LAST FEW WEEKS. WITHOUT A
REALLY COMPREHENSIVE VIEW OF
WHAT WE'RE DOING AND WHAT THE-
REAL REPERCUSSIONS OF OUR
ACTIONS ARE GOING TO BE AND
THAT IS OF HUGE CONCERN TO. BUT
WHENIT COMES TO JUST THE
SPELLING I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
THE WORKABILITY I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT THE DEFINITIONS BEYOND
CLEAR I HOPE WE LANDED ON EARTH
DID WE GET A COPY OF THE
LETTER. YEAH I WAS JUST THERE
WAS STANDING HERE WAS JUST
DELIVERED TO ME SO I WAS GONNA
HANG I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU A
OPPORTUNITY BEFORE I FINISH TO
READ IT OUT LOUD TO EVERYBODY.
OKAY IS THAT THE LETTER TO THE
JOURNAL. ALL LEGISLATIVE INTENT
INTENT YEAH WHY DON'T I LET YOU
READ IT BEFORE IT CAN COME.
OKAY I HAVEN'T READ IT MYSELF.
WELL GIVE ME A MINUTE.
S. H.
ONE. WELCOME. OKAY YOU CAN READ
IT PLEASE. HI THIS IS TO THE
SECRETARY THE SENATE GERMANS
CONTROLLERS THE PURPOSE OF THIS
LETTER IS TO EXPRESS MY INTENT
AND THEN ACTING SENATE BILL
FIFTY ONE WHICH PROVIDES FOR AN
ALTERNAIVE ELECTION FOR
CERTAIN TAXPAYERS RECEIVING
CALIFORNIA COMPETES TAX CREDITS
AWARDS AND WHO COMMIT TO
IRREVOCABLE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT INVESTMENTS. IT IS%
MY INTENT THAT IN PARAGRAPH.
FIVE PARENTHESES CAPITAL A OF
SUBDIVISION SMALL BE SECTION
ONE SEVEN OH FIVE NINE POINT
TWO AND IN PARAGRAPH FIVE A OF
SUBDIVISION B. OF SECTION
TWENTY THREE SIX EIGHTY NINE
QUOTE UNQUOTE QUALIFY TAXPAYER
MEANS A TAXPAYER THAT WILL
PROSPECTIVELY AND CUMULATIVELY
CREATE AT LEAST FIVE THOUSAND
PREVAILING WAGE FULL TIME OR
FULL TIME EQUIVALENT NEW JOBS
IN THE STATE. EACH YEAR OVER
THE NUMBER OF JOBS EXISTING IN
THE PREVIOUS YEAR FOR A PERIOD
OF TEN YEARS AFTER THE
EFFECTIVE DATE OF THE AWARD IT
IS ALSO MY INTENT THAT IN
PARAGRAPH FOUR OF SUBDIVISION
BE. SECTION ONE SEVEN ZERO FIVE
NINE POINT TWO. AND PARAGRAPH
FOUR OF SUBDIVISION B. OF
SECTION. TWENTY THREE SIX
EIGHTY NINE CLINICAL IMMOBILE
CAPITAL EQUIPMENT. DOES NOT
INCLUDE ANY EQUIPMENT THAT WAS
BUILT OR INSTALLED AS A
CONDITION OF AN EARLIER
CALIFORNIA COMPETES TAX CREDIT
REQUIREMENTS. ALSO I CAN FIND
THAT LEAVE THAT WITH YOU LATER
SO DOCTOR CARD DOES THAT ANSWER
YOUR QUESTIONS COOL COOL COOL.
YES THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND PER
YEAR FOR TEN YEARS IS WHAT THE
BILLS WERE. SO IT SOUNDS LIKE
FIFTY THOUSAND JOBS WHAT APPLE
DON'T MAKE ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND
I'M SORRY I DIDN'T QUITE I'M
SORRY HE SAID WHAT HAPPENS I
KNOW IT'S HARD TO HEAR THROUGH
THAT ALL OF OUR MASKS AND
THINGS- HE SAID WHAT HAPPENS IF
THEY DON'T REACH THAT FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS I FIVE
THOUSAND JOBS NEW JOBS PER YEAR.
WELL IN CALIFORNIA- CALIFORNIA
COMPETES THEY HAVE. A SYSTEM OF
ADDRESSING THAT AND I REMEMBER
OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD BUT THEY
DO HAVE A SYSTEM TO ADDRESS AND
NOT GIVE THAT CREDIT OR PULL
BACK ON THE CREDIT IS I
REMEMBER ANYTHING CAL COMPETES
IS USUALLY VERY I'M STRINGENT
ON ON THEIR ON THE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THOSE
CREDITS WHICH I DO GIVE HIM
CREDIT. FOR SO YES THEY THEY
USUALLY ARE ARE ARE GOOD ABOUT
THAT. THAT BEING SAID THANK YOU
FOR READING THE LETTER I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT EVERYBODY HERE
AND I APPRECIATE THAT IT THAT
IT IS GOING TO CLARIFY SOME OF
THE DEFINITIONS THAT ARE. NOT
CLEAR IN THE BILL RIGHT NOW-
WITH THAT IN THE WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND MISTER
MATHIS. GIVE US A MOTION MR
MAYS GAVE US IN SECONDS-
SENATOR CALDERON WOULD YOU LIKE
I MEAN CENTER LORD JESUS. I
MEAN HELP ME. THIRD TORONTO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I JUST
I UNDERSTAND I MEAN
CALIFORNIA'S NOT MADE UP BY ONE
INDUSTRY THERE'S NO WAY WE CAN
BE THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD IF WE'RE DEPENDENT ON
ANY ONE INDUSTRY SO ARGUE WITH
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES THAT ARE
INVESTMENTS HAVE TO BE
DIVERSIFIED AND WE ARE
DIVERSIFIED THAT'S WHY WE SUCH
A GREAT STATE. SO I DON'T THINK
THIS PRECLUDES US NOR SHOULD IT
HASN'T STOPPED US IN THE PAST
NOW SHOULD STOP US IN THE
FUTURE. FROM LOOKING. EIGHT AND
WE HELP- OTHER INDUSTRIES SO I
WAS JUST FOCUSED ON THIS ONE
BUT AGAIN ON. YOU KNOW I DON'T
THINK THIS MEANS THAT WE DON'T
ASSIST ANY OTHER INDUSTRY WE
CAN'T SURVIVE AS A GREAT STATE.
IF WE JUST HAVE ONE INDUSTRY.
MISTER CALDERON. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I'LL JUST SAY I'M WITH
HER I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING
THAT SHE SAID I REALLY RESPECT
MY COLLEAGUES ARE COMING FROM I
TOTALLY UNDERSTAND I WISH I WAS
GOING TO BE HERE ANOTHER YEAR
TO WORK WITH EVERYBODY ON THIS
ISSUE- BUT I KNOW HOW CAPABLE
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF YOU ARE AND
I KNOW THAT YOU'LL FIGURE THIS
OUT- AND I WILL ABSOLUTELY BE
CHEERLEADING FROM THE SIDELINES
AND- HELP IN ANY WAY THAT I
POSSIBLY CAN- CAN'T ALTHOUGH. I
THINK I CAN REALLY DO MUCH FOR
ABOUT A YEAR SO ROUTE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS POLICY. I'M SURE
THERE IS PLENTY YOU'LL BE ABLE
TO DO- WITH THAT- MISTER RUFF
WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. BURKE NOT
VOTING BURKE NOT VOTING MATHIS
HI MATHIS HI KILEY. KILEY NOT
VOTING YOU ARE CHIU HI GREAT.
GREAT I LEVINE. LEVINE I MAYES
AYE MAYES HI MULLIN. MULLIN I
PETRIE-NORRIS. PETRIE-NORRIS
AYE CORK AYE FIFTY THOUSAND
JOBS. SIXTEEN I'M SORRY SIR HE
SAID FOR FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
FIFTY THOUSAND JOBS IT'S CHEAP.
WORK I'D- THREE OF US.
THREE OF US HI. THE BILL HAS
NINE VOTES THE MEASURE PASSES
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK BEING
COLLEAGUES. AND  SAW SENATOR
BRADFORD PIECING BY THE DOOR IS
HE STILL OUTSIDE CAN WE HAVE
THE START. YES THEY ARE HERE-
MOVING FILE ITEM TO SB FOURTEEN
FORTY SEVEN BRADFORD OR CENTER
CABALLERO WHOEVER WOULD LIKE
TO. PRESENT. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS- THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT SB FOURTEEN FORTY
SEVEN- CENTER BRADFORD MAY BE
WALKING IN WE WERE WAITING
OUTSIDE AND HE HAD HE WAS
RUNNING THE SHOW NEXT NEXT DOOR
AND SO- HE WANTED TO CHECK IN
ON IT SO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
BILL SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS HAS FILED AN
EMPLOYMENT KICK CLAIMS AND
PROTECT. PROJECTIONS ARE THE
JOB DISLOCATION SHOULD BE COULD
BE LARGER THAN THAT EXPERIENCE
STRICT DURING THE GREAT
DEPRESSION AND THE NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN INFLUENZA EPIDEMIC THE
CALIFORNIA- ACTUALLY STARTED
THE WRONG TYPE SORRY- SO LET ME
START OVER AND SAY THANK YOU-
THIS IS A CRITICAL MASS MEASURE
THAT WILL PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT%
ASSISTANCE TO OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES AS THEY STRUGGLE
WITH THE DEVASTATING IMPACTS OF
CORBETT NINETEEN I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO EXTEND MY APPRECIATION
TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR THOROUGH REVIEW OF THIS
ISSUE PROVIDED TO THE IN IN IN
IN THE ANALYSIS. AS YOU ARE
AWARE THE CORONA VIRUS PANDEMIC
HAS HAD AN UNPRECEDENTED AFFECT
ON CALIFORNIANS AND IT'S
DEVASTATED THOUSANDS OF SMALL
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE OF THE
RESTAURANT AND HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRIES WHICH PREDOMINATELY
PREDOMINATELY EMPLOYEE LATINOS
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR COLOR AS
THE DATA HAS SHOWN. THESE ARE
ALSO THE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN THE MOST HEAVILY IMPACTED
BY THE CORONA VIRUS. AND DEBT
IT IT IT F. ILLNESSES AND
DEATHS ACCORDING TO THE
NATIONAL ACADEMY OF SCIENCES
48% OF AMERICAN WORKERS ARE
EMPLOYED BY SMALL BUSINESSES
THEIR FATE IS CLOSELY TIED TO
THE RESILIENCY OF THE SMALL
BUSINESS ECOSYSTEM. AND THE
MASSIVE ECONOMIC DISRUPTION
CAUSED BY THE PANDEMIC SENATE
SINCE THE ONSET OF THE VIRUS
AND THE SHELTER IN PLACE ORDER
MY GOD THE GOVERNOR CALIFORNIA
HAS EXPERIENCED HISTORIC JOB
LOSSES. WITH WITH WITHIN THE
FIRST MONTH NEARLY HALF OF
SMALL BUSINESSES TEMPORARILY
CLOSED AND THEY REPORTED HAVING
REDUCED THEIR ACTIVE EMPLOYMENT
BY 40% THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT. DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT ANNOUNCED IN JUNE
THAT THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
PEAKED AT SIXTEEN POINT 3%
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN THE
PEAK UNEMPLOYMENT RATE OF
TWELVE POINT 3% DURING THE
GREAT RECESSION. WHILE RECENT
NUMBERS HAVE SHOWN A MODEST
IMPROVEMENT THERE IS NO TRUE
AND INSIGHT. AB FOURTEEN FORTY
SEVEN PROVIDES A DIRECT
INCENTIVE TO SMALL BUSINESSES
TO HIRE EMPLOYEES MANY OF WHOM
HAVE WORKED AT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES FOR YEARS. SB
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN ALLOW
SMALL BUSINESSES TO RECEIVE A
TAX CREDIT OF A THOUSAND
DOLLARS BEGINS PERSONAL AND
CORPORATE INCOME TAXES OR SALES
AND USE TAXES FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY TAX YEAR. FOR EACH NET
NEW EMPLOYEE HIRED BY THAT
BUSINESS SO LONG AS ALL OF THE
FOLLOWING APPLIES THE SMALL
BUSINESS EMPLOYED ONE HUNDRED
OR FEWER EMPLOYEES AS OF
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
NINETEEN. THE SMALL BUSINESS
HAD A 50% DECREASE IN GROSS
RECEIPTS IN THE SECOND QUARTER
OF TWENTY TWENTY. THIS SMALL
BUSINESS HAD A NET INCREASE IN
EMPLOYMENT BETWEEN JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THROUGH NOVEMBER
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY AS
COMPARED TO THE SECOND QUARTER
OF TWENTY TWENTY. AND THE SMALL
BUSINESS APPLIED FOR A
TENTATIVE KERR CREDIT
REGISTRATIONUNDER THIS BILL.
BETWEEN DECEMBER FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY AND JANUARY FIFTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION. AT A
TIME WHEN MANY OF OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE DEBATING WHETHER
THEY WILL EVER REOPEN OR BE
ABLE TO COME BACK TO THE PRE
COVERED STATE THEY NEED OUR
SUPPORT MORE THAN EVER. I'M
PROUD TO- BE HERE WITH SENATOR
BRADFORD WHO OFTEN OBVIOUSLY IS
NOT HERE RIGHT NOW- AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. WELL IF SENATOR
AFTER MAKES IT BACK WILL LET
HIM. HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY I
UNDERSTAND THERE IS ONE PRIMARY
WHEN IT'S IN SUPPORT. OUR
PRIMARY WITNESSES JAMIE
CHAMBERLIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE APPEARING BY TELEPHONE
WITH THE MODERATOR PLEASE
CONNECT US
MONITOR. MISTER. J. TRAVELING
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. OKAY GREAT WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON- THEY SHOULDN'T TAKE
HIM ALONG WITH THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON S.
B. FOURTEEN FORTY SIX. SURE IF
YOU WEEKS AGO GOVERNOR NEWSOM.
ANNOUNCED HIS DESIRE TO CREATE
A MAIN STREET HIRING CREDIT TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO SMALL
BUSINESSES. DURING THIS
UNPRECEDENTED ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN. LEAD MINISTRATIONS
VERY PLEASED TO PARTNER WITH
SENATOR BRADFORD CENTER
COPYRIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SPONTANEOUS. BRING FOR THIS
BILL TO CREATE A TAX CREDIT
WILL PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATED BY THE CODE AND THEN.
ADULT BURDENS AND BENEFITS
PRIOR TO ME. REHIRING EMPLOYEES
THAT HAVE BEEN LAID OFF THE
RESEARCH I'VE DONE ON THE
CLAIM. THIS PAST SPRING. I
THINK THE REPUBLIC OKAY BECAUSE
JOB DESCRIBING. OTHER OTHER
CREDIT WILL CATCH ONE HIGHLIGHT.
OF THE CREDIT SO FIRST IS THE
PUBLIC SPEECHES THAT HOW THE
QUALIFICATIONS FOR THOSE
CREDITS ARE BASED OFF OF THE
SAME PARAMETERS. A CALL FOR THE
PROJECT ATTACK CREDIT FOR THE
DROP ARE THE CARE. AND THE CALL
CAME ARE THE BILL AFTER THAN
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES AND THEY ALSO
HAD TO HAVE A SIGNIFICANT TO
TALK DECLINE IN REVENUE-
CONFORMING TO THE SEVERAL
PARAMETERS FOR THE PAYROLL TAX
REVENUE MAKE IT EASIER FOR
BUSINESSES. TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THEY QUALIFY FOR THE
HIRING CREDIT. THE SECOND
SECOND POINT IS THAT- THIS WILL
TAKE THE ABILITY OF BUSINESSES
ACTUALLY USE THE CREDIT- AS THE
ELDEST TYPICAL THE CREDIT IS
ALLOWED AGAINST. INCOME TAX AND
CORPORATE TAX BUT BECAUSE MANY
BUSINESSES WILL NOT HAVE
TAXABLE INCOME- IN TWENTY
TWENTY WE ALSO. IS CREDITED
LOCAL LAWS. ARE TO BE
THEMSELVES. THAT IS A FIVE YEAR
PERIOD THE CREDIT ON BOTH. THE
SALES TAX BY THE- NET INCOME
TAX. FINALLY THIS IS A VERY
GOOD ESTIMATES WHAT THE WHAT
THE COST OF THIS CREDIT WILL BE
WE DON'T REALLY HAVE HAD REAL
GOOD DATA ON HOW MANY
BUSINESSES ARE GOING TO MEET.
THE CRITERIA FOR THE CREDIT
THEREFORE THE CREDIT IS CAPTAIN
ALLOCATED TO REPEAT THE FISCAL
FISCAL UNCERTAINTY FOR THE
STATE. LOCAL CREDIT IS GOING TO
TRY. A MUCH NEEDED SUPPORT TO
BOTH SMALL BUSINESSES AND TO
AVOID COULD NOT HARM. A BUDGET
MONTH DECLINE BROUGHT ABOUT BY
THE PANDEMIC- THAT CONCLUDES MY
COMMENTS- THANKS FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. HERE A IT'S MODERATE
WOULD PLEASE OPEN UP THE
MAINLINE TRANSITIONAL SUPPORT
TESTIMONY.
HUTTERITE ARE IS
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
ARE YOU STILL THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CHANNEL ONE ISN'T SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. HELLO. WITH
THE MODERATOR PLEASE NOW OPEN
THE MAIN LINE FOR ANY
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE ZERO
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION. MADAM
CHAIR NO ONE HAS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU ISTHERE
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION BE A REMOTE VOTING
STATION AT THIS TIME. SEEING
NONE IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THING NINE COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
DR KIRK. ALL YEP. WELL WHEN.
ALL DR KIRK I DON'T YOU'RE MIKE
IS ON THIS TO BE IMPOSSIBLE.
BUT SHE GOOD IN TERMS
PROJECTIONS IS VERY SHE'S GOING
TO SO MY CONCERN IS THAT THE-
THESE CREDITS BY LARGE DON'T
CREATE NEW JOBS. ON THE OTHER
HAND IS BUSINESSES DO DESERVE-
BREAK DURING THIS THE REQUESTED
I HAVE THEM WHAT THEY POINT OUT
HERE IS FIRST HOME MOST OF THE
SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE THAT IN
MY DISTRICT HAVE FAR LESS THAN
A HUNDRED EMPLOYEES. THOSE THAT
DO HAVE A HUNDRED ARE LARGER
MORE SOPHISTICATED AND THE
CONCERN HERE IS THAT IT WOULD
BE THESE. THAT THE MOM AND POP
BUSINESSES WOULDN'T BE
SOPHISTICATED ENOUGH TO REALLY
APPLY FOR THIS IS THERE
ANYTHING IN THE BUILD THAT SORT
OF- WOULD BE ABLE TO EDUCATE
CONSOLIDATIONS- TO APPLY FOR
THE BILL. FOR EXCUSE ME APPLY
FOR THE CREDIT. THERE'S NOTHING
IN THE- IN ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THERE'S NOTHING IN THE BILL
THAT PROVIDES TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE BUT WE EXPECT THAT
WE- THAT THAT THERE IS SUCH A
NEED FOR RESOURCES FOR
BUSINESSES THAT. THAT SENDING
THE INFORMATION TO THE OUR
LOCAL- SMALL BUSINESS
ASSOCIATIONS- WILL HELP TO GET
THE WORD OUT AND- AND WE HAVE
TO RELY ON THEM IT'S A ONE YEAR
PROGRAM AND THE WHOLE IDEA IS
TO GET IS TO GET. BUSINESS
BUSINESS IS UP AND RUNNING AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AND SO-
WELL WE'LL HAVE TO RELY ON OUR
LOCAL SBDC STIFF TO BE ABLE TO
PUSH OUT THE INFORMATION. OKAY
THANKS. MISTER MATHIS OKAY
TEACHING YEAH BUT I MEAN THE
FIRST. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- CENTER I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I KNOW A LOT OF US HAVE
BEEN ASKING- TO SEE SOME
LEGISLATION LIKE THIS TO SEE
THAT ARE SMALL BUSINESSES GET
HELP- WE DO A LOT OF WORK- BACK
IN MY DISTRICT WITH KOBE IS
WITH OUR CHAMBERS ON MAKING
SURE THAT THESE BUSINESSES ARE
AWARE OF THESE PROGRAMS- SO
HELP ANSWER MISTER COURSE
QUESTION I DEFINITELY REACH
OUT. ONTO YOUR CHAMBERS AND
STUFF AND LET THEM NOW. AS AS
REPUBLICAN IT'S GOOD TO SEE THE
GOVERNOR ACTUALLY LISTEN- SAW
WITH THAT ALL MOTION TO MOVE
THIS BILL FORWARD. IF WE CAN
GET A SECOND. THANK YOU SIR. WE
HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND.
MATHIS THE MOTION BY MATHIS AND
SECOND BY PETRIE-NORRIS AND
THEN THE SUMMER KILEY DID YOU
HAVE A- AND SO I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS I THINK THAT THIS
TAX CUT IS FINE AND MAYBE IT'LL
HELP SOME SMALL BUSINESSES ON
THE MARGIN BUT- I THINK IT'S
SORT OF A SAD COMMENTARY ON-
THE WORK PRODUCT OF THE
LEGISLATURE HER THESE LAST FEW
MONTHS. THIS IS KIND OF WHAT
WE'VE LANDED ON IS THE WAY
WE'RE GOING TO HELP OUT. SMALL
BUSINESSES A THOUSAND DOLLAR
TAX CREDIT I MEAN THERE ARE ALL
KINDS OF THINGS THAT WE'RE
DOING TO SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
WOULD BE WORTH A LOT MORE THAN
A THOUSAND DOLLARS IF WE SIMPLY
STOP DOING THEM. IN FACT THERE
ARE NEW THINGS THAT WE'RE
CONSIDERING DOING THEY'RE GONNA
BE ON THE FLOOR TONIGHT-
THAT'LL COST THEM A LOT MORE
THAN A THOUSAND DOLLARS- SO-
AGAIN I'LL ALSO PUT THE BILL-
BUT I WOULD HOPE THAT. FOLKS
WHO ARE ALSO SUPPORTING IT
WOULD- AT THE REASONS THAT YOU
ARE GOING TO SUPPORT THIS
FIELD- THOSE WILL BE BORNE IN
MIND AS WE CONSIDER- OTHER
LEGISLATION- TODAY AND IN THE
FUTURE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIVING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. CHAIRMAN
AND THANK YOU CENTER CABALLERO
FOR PRESENTING THIS BILL. I
SURE. CRITICISM MAYBE NOT THE
EXACT SAME CRITICISM THAT THAT
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THE BILL AND
I HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT IT AND IN
INTO MEDIUM GOING TO VOTE NO.
WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF TIME
BEFORE IT GETS BEFORE ME ON THE
FLOOR BUT I'M GOING TO CONTINUE
THINKING ABOUT IT. IT IT SEEMS
AS THOUGH THAT. YOU KNOW THIS
IS A MORE OF A PRODUCT. OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THEN IT
IS A OF THE LEGISLATURE. AND IT
SEEMS THAT IT'S- GOT A GREAT.
KIND OF A- A CAMPAIGN HE KICK
TO IT. WE'RE GETTING OUT OF THE
PANDEMIC RECESSION AND LOOK AT
ALL THE JOBS. THAT WE'RE
CREATING. AS WE'RE GETTING OUT
OF THIS BUT IT'S CHERRY
PICKING. BECAUSE THESE ARE
BUSINESSES THAT ARE ACTUALLY.
KIND OF ON THE ON THE GLIDE
PATH UP. OUT OF THE PANDEMIC
RECESSION AS WERE OPENING UP
THE ECONOMY. AND WE'RE EASING
THAT GLIDE PATH UP WE'RE
PUTTING MORE WIND- IT BUT
BENEATH THEM. AND IN FACT WERE.
HELPING THEM HIRE EMPLOYEES
WHEN. THEIR BUSINESS MODEL.
WOULD PROBABLY NECESSITATE
HIRING EMPLOYEES BECAUSE
BUSINESS IS RETURNING TO THEM
AND I AM HAPPY FOR THEM. I AM
SO. AMAZINGLY HAPPY FOR THEM.
THAT HE ARE ABLE TO HIRE PEOPLE
AGAIN. THAT THEY CAN MAKE MONEY
THAT THEY CAN PAY THEIR RENT.
THEY CAN PAY MORTGAGES THEY CAN
PAY LOANS- THAT BUSINESS IS
RETURNING. AND IT'S NICE TO
THINK THAT WE COULD REWARD THEM
FOR IT. BUT THERE ARE PEOPLE
WITH THEIR LIFE SAVINGS JUST
COMPLETELY SHREDDED. THAT ARE
NOT GETTING HELP. THROUGH THIS
AND SO I'M REALLY STRUGGLING.
WITH THE CONCEPT HERE WHERE WE
ARE WE ARE REALLY TAKING SOME
EASY WINS. WITH A TAX CREDIT SO
THAT WE CAN CLAIM THAT WE'VE
CREATED MORE JOBS THROUGH OUR
LEGISLATION. WHEN IN FACT THESE
ARE JOBS THAT PROBABLY WOULD BE
CREATED BY GROWING ECONOMY
ANYWAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT IF
THERE'S NO QUESTION THERE BUT-
I GUESS IT DEPENDS ON. WHAT
YOU'RE DISTRICT LOOKS LIKE- I
HAVE I HAPPEN TO HAVE A VERY
MUCH LIKE ASSEMBLY. MEMBER CORK
SAID- MAJORITY OF THE
BUSINESSES IN MY IN MY DISTRICT
ARE SMALL BUSINESSES AND NOT A
LARGE MAJORITY OF THEM ARE
OWNED. BY IMMIGRANTS- PEOPLE
THAT ARRIVED HERE WITH NOTHING
AND HAVE BEEN WORKING THEIR
ENTIRE LIFE TO BE ABLE TO. TO
PROVIDES A LOT OF THEM FOOD-
THERE ISN'T THERE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS THAT ARE THAT ARE
GROWING STUFF. AND THE ABILITY
TO ACTUALLY- TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
A TAX CREDIT THAT'S THAT'S
THERE THAT'LL HELP HIM YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT IT'S CREDIT
THAT'S GOING TO. PUT SOME AIR
UNDER THE WINGS BUT RIGHT NOW-
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IS ANY
ERROR UNDER ANY BUSINESSES
WINGS IS GOING TO BE REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE- THE MINUTE
THAT PEOPLE START. WORKING FULL
TIME OR- OR THEY CAN HIRE MORE
PEOPLE TO COME AND DO THE WORK-
THE BETTER THE ECONOMY'S GOING
TO BE AND THAT REALLY HELPS THE
LOCAL ECONOMY FOR PEOPLE HAVE
CASH TO BE ABLE TO PAY THE RENT
TO BUY GROCERIES AND DO. TO THE
NECESSITY FOR THE NECESSITY
NECESSITY SO I DO APPRECIATE
YOUR YOUR YOUR POSITION BUT-
AND COULD WE HAVE DONE MORE
ABSOLUTELY I MEAN I WILL TELL
YOU THAT I AM VOTING RIGHT NOW
ON BILLS. THAT I WISH WE HAD
DONE MORE. BUT YOU KNOW WE HAVE
LIMITED RESOURCES AND SO WE DO
THE BEST THAT WE CAN WITH THE
LIMITED RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT I DO
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU
SENATOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PITCHING OR PETRIE-NORRIS.
EIGHT YOUR MY PHONE YEAH TWO
TEAMS SENATOR AND SHEER YOUR
FELLOW AUTHORS THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I THINK
YOU KNOW AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM
ALL OF US WE NEED TO RIGHT NOW
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO HELP
STABILIZE CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESSES THEY ARE THE HEART
AND SOUL OF CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY THEY ARE THE HEART AND
SOUL OF SO MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND ISSUE SAID THE
EMPLOYEE THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS ALL ACROSS THE
STATE I'M IN IT TOOK SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS. IS THIS
F. R. WE DONE NOT EVEN CLOSE
AND YOU KNOW THIS IS VERY MUCH
I THINK JUST THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG AND I KNOW THAT THIS IS
AN ISSUE I'M PASSIONATE ABOUT
ANDERSON IF YOU'RE PASSIONATE
ABOUT AND I THINK IT'S
ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT THAT WE
CONTINUE AS WE THINK ABOUT THE
FOLLOWING THINK ABOUT NEXT YEAR
THAT WE CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON
DOING EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN TO
STABILIZE CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESS THAT HELPED THEM
SURVIVE THIS CRISIS AND
POSITION THEM TO THRIVE AS WE
THOUGHT CALIFORNIA ON A PATH TO
RECOVERY SEVEN BUT THAT I'M
VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT PEOPLE.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE SENATOR WOULD YOU
TO CLOSE. MEMBERS ASK FOR YOUR
I. THANK YOU THE ARE. TO PURSUE
HERE TONIGHT THINK YOU MR OF
CALLED. WITH THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE FLOOR. BURKE HI
BURKE HI MATHIS MATHIS HI KILEY.
KILEY HI TO CHIU HI GREAT. HI
GREAT HI LEVINE YOU KNOW LET ME
KNOW MAYES. MAYES FIVE MULLIN-
MULLIN HI PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS HI CORK. QUIRK I
THREE OF US. THREE OF US I.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
THE BILL HAS TEN BUCKS THE BILL
DOWN THE NEXT STEP THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN FILE
ITEM THREE AB TWO SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE
READY. MOVE THE BILL SECOND.
THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I THINK THIS MAY BE MY
FIRST TIME IN FRONT OF YOUR
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HELP ON THE STOCK I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
ALL OF YOUR HELP I'M AB TWO
SEVENTY SIX PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS WHO FACED WITH
ECONOMIC HARDSHIP TO THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC TAKE A LOAN
FROM THEIR OWN EMPLOYER
SPONSORED QUALIFIED RETIREMENT
PLAN. TO SUPPORT THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES AB TWO SEVENTY
SIX CONFORMS STATE LAW THE
PROVISION OF THE FEDERAL
CORONAVIRUS AID RELIEF AND
ECONOMIC SECURITY AFTER THE
CARES ACT THAT REMOVES
PENALTIES FOR THOSE TAKING A
LOAN FROM THEIR EMPLOYER
SPONSORED DEFINED CONTRIBUTION
PROGRAM. THE CALIFORNIA
PERSONAL INCOME TAX CODE DOES
NOT CONFORM TO THE CARES ACT.
WITH RESPECT TO THE AUTOMATIC
SUSPENSION OF A 10% PENALTY.
FOR EARLY DISTRIBUTION FROM
RETIREMENT PLAN. HOWEVER IT
DOES NOT AUTOMATICALLY SORRY IT
DOES CONFORM TO THE CARES ACT
BUT IT DOESN'T CONFORM TO THE
CARES ACT AUTOMATICALLY TO THE
PARALLEL PENALTY RELIEF FROM
LOANS FROM QUALIFY PLANS. TO
PEOPLE CAN TAKE THE LOANS BUT
THEY GET HIT WITH A PENALTY.
DURING THIS PANDEMIC MANY
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE FACED WITH
UNEMPLOYMENT AND OTHER ECONOMIC
HARDSHIPS ARE TAKING EXACTLY
THESE LOANS. FROM THEIR
RETIREMENT ACCOUNTS AND WE
SHOULD ENCOURAGE THEM TO BE
PAYING THOSE LOANS BACK. SO
THOSE INDIVIDUALS CONTINUE TO
PLAN FOR THEIR- FINANCIAL
STABILITY DOWN THE ROAD. EIGHTY
TWO SEVENTY SIX MINIMIZES THE
CHANCES OF AN INDIVIDUAL IN A
VIRTUALLY BEING SUBJECT TO A
CALIFORNIA TAX PENALTY. BECAUSE
THEY WERE UNDER THE MISTAKEN
ASSUMPTION THAT CALIFORNIA LAW
AND FEDERAL LAW OVER ONE IN THE
SAME WHEN IT COMES TO THESE
LOANS. AB TWO SEVENTY SIX IS
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA I
GOT TO COUNCIL IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT UNION COALITION.
JASON FOX FOR THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF CPA'S AND KATHY
GRIMACED SEE. OUR OUR SPONSOR
FROM OUR SPONSORS WILL VOICE
HER SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE IF
THEY ARE STILL ON THE PHONE.
AND I REQUEST WE REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU I IS JASON FOX
FROM THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
CPA'S OR ITS COUNTERPARTS ON
THE LINE. HI YES. BOX WOULD BE
CALIFORNIA STUDY A CERTIFIED
PUBLIC ACCOUNTANT- IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO THOUSAND SIX I'LL BE
BRIEF- THE FROM THE WOMAN-
COVERED B. THE MAJOR PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL. THE NARROW BUT
IMPORTANT THING FOR ME MEASURE
AND THAT THE PRACTITIONER CAN'T
POINT TO FOR TEAMS STATE
FEDERAL TAX LAWS GREATLY
REDUCES COMPLICATIONS CONFUSION
BUT OTHER CHALLENGES THE THING
WITH TAX COMPLIANCE. THANK YOU
FROM THE WOMANAT THE COMMITTEE
AND COMMITTEE STAFF AND WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT. OF AB TWO SEVEN
CORRECT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ARE THERE IS THERE A- WHAT INSP.
I BELIEVE KATHY GRAHAM AS HE
WAS GOING TO BE ON THE LINE SO
MAYBE THE OPERATOR COULD LOOK
FOR HER THIS CAT GRAHAM
MENZIES. ONLINE. WHILE WE'RE
WAITING WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
MR MATHESON AND SECOND FOR
MISTER GRAY. ONE MORE TIME I'M
GONNA ASK FOR KATHY GRAHAM AS
HE. MADAM CHAIR WE'RE NOT
SHOWING HER ON THE LINE
PRESENTLY THANK YOU SO MUCH DO
WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT MISTER
MODERATOR. AND MADAM CHAIR ARE
YOU IF YOU'RE READY TO TAKE
COMMENTS FROM PEOPLE THEY CAN
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT WE ARE
READY FOR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. I'M SURE WE
DO HAVE ONE PERSON QUEUING UP
AND SUPPORT THE OPERATORS
PROCESSING THEM THROUGH BE JUST
ANOTHER MOMENT. THANK YOU. AND
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM LINE
TO SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THE CAT THE GOVERNMENT
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA OUT TO COUNSEL AND
EDUCATE. REPORT THANK YOU.
MYSTERON READER IF THERE'S NO
MORE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ARE
THERE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
IF ANYONE WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME PLEASE. SURE
THERE'S NO WINNING QUEUE AT
THIS TIME PLEASE CONTINUE GREAT
THANK YOU COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE OKAY. WITH THAT
ONE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANKS FOR YOUR
HELP IN CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
MISTER RUFF WOULD YOU CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE. THE MOTION IS TO
RECOMMEND CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS. BURKE I. BURKE FIVE
OFFICE. MATHIS HI KILEY CHARLIE
I'D SHOOT. CHU HI GREAT TO.
GREAT HI LEVINE. HI LEVINE I
MAYES I. MAYES AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS HI CORK WELL.
CORK FIVE THREE OF US
THREE OF US I OCEAN HAS ELEVEN
VOTES THANK NINE BILLS OUT
THINK YOU AND FINALLY WILL TAKE
UP MY BILL AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN FOR THE PURPOSE OF
CONCURRENCE AT THIS POINT I
WOULD HAVE TURNED OVER ALREADY
THE GAVEL ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. I THANK YOU
MEMBERS FOR YOUR PATIENCE TODAY
AND THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
TO PRESENT AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN. IS IT AB FIFTEEN SEVEN
SEVEN IS A STREET FORTY
MINISTRY TO BE FRIENDLY BILL
THAT CONFORMS CALIFORNIA THE
FEDERAL PAYCHECK PROTECTION
PROGRAMS LOAN FORGIVENESS
PROVISION AS MANY BE AWARE THE
CARES ACT ESTABLISHES PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAM TO PROVIDE.
SMALL BUSINESSES SECOND WHEN I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I WILL.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR OF THE- GREAT CLOSING ON
I. BELIEVE YOU HAVE- SOME
WITNESSES ON THE LINE- MISTER
FOX. THANK YOU TALK AGAIN WITH
THE CALPERS TARGET CERTIFIED
PUBLIC ACCOUNTANT IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN AGAIN
I'LL BE BRIEF THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN A COVER THE HIGHLIGHTS OF
THE PROVISION AS WELL THANK BE
FROM ELEMENT THAT THE COMMITTEE
AND THE COMMITTEE STOP THE HARD
WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. I
WOULD SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER
FOR. THERE ANYONE. ELSE WISHING
TO TESTIFY VIA REMOTE VIDEO.
SEE NON MISTER OPERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHERS ON THE LINE- TO
VOICE THEIR SUPPORT. MANY
GERMAN AGAIN TO VOICE YOUR
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. YOU CHAIRED APPEARS
THERE'S NO WINNING QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU IN A SCENE
NO SUPPORT IN THE CHAMBERS-
MISTER MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
IN OPPOSITION. BEIJING GERMAN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. DO
CHAIR THERE'S NO ONE THAT
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
AND ASCENA WITNESSES AND THE
CHAMBER TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AND NINE VIA VIDEO- WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. ANY
MEMBERS WHO WISH TO COMMENT.
SEEN NON WITH ROUGHLY TAKE THE
ROLE. HOW MATTER. ESPECIALLY
REQUESTED I'VE OF. THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO CONCURRENCE
SENATE AMENDMENTS BURKE. BURKE
HI MATHIS AYE MATHIS AYE AYE
KILEY. KILEY AYE CHIU CHIU I
GREAT. GREAT HI LEVINE LEVINE
HI MAYES HI MAYES AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS II CORK. QUIRK I
THREE OF US THREE OF US I AZUR
HAS ELEVEN VOTES THAT MEASURE
IS OUT WITH THAT. SEEING AND
HEARING OKAY WE HAVE. YEAH
RIGHT NOW WE'RE ALL GOOD GOOD
TO CLOSE WITH THAT REVENUE
TAXES ADJOURNED.